alright that's all for today remember we
have two more days though so don't be
too sad is Yan Cheng from Michigan
thanks to Dorothy and David for
organizing the workshop so this is joint
work with inquire who is sitting right
there and we're going to talk about a
lab experiment that looks at information
acquisition and provision in school
choice and the advantage of having the
last talk of the day is a lot of the
concepts are being explained because so
the in the school choice literature you
know students choose which schools to
attend and the centralized matching
mechanism has been very popular in
different parts of the world and
typically you have lots of schools to
rank and in New York City for example
there's a brochure that's about 700
pages long and from the front a brochure
you're supposed to pick 12 schools to
rank so there's a lot of information to
process in college admissions as well
students need to choose which college or
universities to attend and again there
are typically hundreds of colleges and
programs available so the information
problem here is that the relevant
information is for instance the quality
of the school and whether it's a good
match for you personally might be
unavailable or costly to to acquire so
this is a quote from a parent in New
Orleans who says that it was very hard
and very time-consuming to find a school
for her daughter so this is someone the
daughter is attending kindergarten so so
she said I am educated and I have a
bachelor's degree and I do have time to
read articles online research things and
she's doing
quite difficult to to do the ranking and
this classic school choice literature we
just assume that you know people know
their preferences and that's a given
and we're basically looking at you know
how do people find out about their
preferences and and there are also a
fair amount of field experiments and
empirical evidence which showed that
providing more information could change
student choices so there's a field
experiment by Hastings and Weinstein
that looks at I think North Carolina
school choice again the default is a
thick brochure where the alphabetically
ranked schools so the authors actually
distill them to a three page summary of
the feasible schools and rent them by
the you know school quality measured by
standardized tests and they find that
that systematically changes parents
rankings and that you know the more
academically demanding schools are in
higher demand in their intervention the
other piece of information is looking at
information on financial aid so there's
a paper by Hawks B and Turner and the
title actually says it all and the title
is you know what do high achieving and
low-income students know about colleges
and the answer is not much lots of them
for instance would apply for their their
local their public university in the
state thinking that the private
universities are not not a financially
at a noble but not knowing that the
financial aid actually is is quite
generous in a lot of private schools and
there are also a lot more examples so in
this paper we're going to look at
students incentives to acquire
information about their own preferences
so this is a departure from the the
school choice literature or the the
classic school choice literature we
assume that this is in a private value
environment and also for others
preference
so this is for strategic considerations
we're also going to look at how their
incentives might vary under different
school choice mechanisms and we also
measured the welfare effects of
information provision by the education
authorities so in the end I'm going to
talk about several real-world examples
of the educational authorities supplying
information so we have a theoretical
model this this used to be one paper now
it's split into two papers so the in in
the theoretical paper we characterized
the optimal strategies for the students
and then I'm going to focus on the lab
experiment which provides empirical
evidence and also because we're using
disvalue methods we could we could do
counterfactual analysis
so there is an extensive literature on
information acquisition and in the
mechanism design context is most of this
literature is in the auction context and
there are a few papers or information
acquisition in matching and I'm going to
once I present our results I'm going to
come back and revisit some of these
experiments it turns out that the one
finding that we see in our data which is
over acquisition it's quite prevalent in
previous example as well and there's
also a literature or advice given in
school choice and that's the in that
setting the the information is exogenous
so like it or not you're going to get
advice whereas in our case we we measure
the the incentives to acquire
information so so I'm going to quickly
go through the theoretical analysis that
provides the benchmark for I experiment
design and focus primarily on the
experiment results so a typical school
choice problem consists of a set of
students and a set of schools each
school has a quota for simplicity we say
that the schools don't rank students
ex-ante and so you use a random lottery
exposed and there are very information
structures and preferences so the
previous literature you assumes that the
ordinal preference or the cardinal
preferences no and under this set of
assumptions you know the canonical
school choice mechanisms include the
Galle Shapley deferred acceptance or the
Boston immediate acceptance mechanism
which Qatar
has introduced and the strategy in the
setting is that the students will submit
a rank order list of schools so I'm
going to now just give the slide so we
in our experiment we compare these two
mechanisms the Boston immediate
acceptance and Gil Shapley deferred
acceptance so the one part to remember
about the immediate acceptance mechanism
is that it's not a strategy proof for
the DA you know matching at every step
is temporary until the algorithm
terminates so truth-telling is a
dominant strategy
so information acquisition in our
setting essentially put a game a staged
game before the school choice game so
now you have two stages so you before
you submit the rank order loads there's
common knowledge of the distribution of
the school values but you don't know the
realization so the customer information
acquisition is a sequential acquisition
process so you've you invest you first
invest in acquiring ordinal preferences
alpha which is bounded and and then if
you are in but you might invest in
acquiring cardinal preferences so one
way to think about this about ordinal
and Cardinal preference in this setting
is that Cardinal preferences more in
depth information about you know a
particular score in the experiment
actually collapse these two stages
together so this is I know this is a
little bit busy the process the
technology for information acquisition
our own values so nature draws your
Cardinal preference you're cutting your
preferences VI which implies or your
ordinal preference so at this point I
know everyone knows the distribution and
so player I decides whether to acquire
information or ordinal preferences if
you decide not to you enter the school
choice game just knowing the
distribution and if you decide to
acquire information so alpha is how much
you invest in information acquisition
you can think of sending your child to a
school and spend a day you know
shadowing the students and so on or you
can choose to read their webpage so so I
chooses the amount to pay to acquire
information and with probability a of
alpha you learned the information now
with probability one minus alpha
you don't again you would enter the
school choice game only
the distribution after knowing ordinal
preferences you can decide whether to
invest more to acquire the cardinal
preferences if you decide to invest
again what certain probability would
probably be a beta you know your via
your partner preference and if you
decide not to invest and or you invest
but you know you didn't get the
information you entered the school
choice game only knowing your ordinal
preference yes David requiring all of my
auto information or just on some
comparisons of scores so in the example
so in the example in the experiment
we're just talking about one school but
this could be you know the the profile
of let's say 12 schools
and what is the role of the probability
in your in your own in your in your
model because I you could have written
that all down I think without the
probability piece yeah so so you could
so the idea is you you went let's say
your child goes to a school and spend
the day you know made the investment but
still couldn't decide whether you know
whether that was a good match or not
play a technical role as well would
things not go through without the
probabilities you know what's going to
answer that question
modeling choice to capture the intensity
how much you want to invest okay so I'm
going to talk about the two
characterizations which is two
propositions about the each mechanism so
we first looked at the incentive to
acquire information about own
preferences so under the bound it costs
and the anodic conditions for the
technology we we have that in any
symmetric visi Nash equilibrium students
always have an incentive to learn their
own ordinal preferences and under the a
there's no incentive to learn their own
cardinal preferences whereas under IA
there is a distribution there exists a
distribution of preferences such that
students have an incentive to learn
their own cardinal preferences
and the third part is true for all
strategy proof mechanisms that elisa
ordinary information from students
and then the yeah
I explained another yeah so the another
condition you mean
so for the the technology so it's if you
invest nothing you you get nothing
the the the the a is 0 and its concave
so the marginal return for investment at
0 is approaches infinity whereas it goes
to 0 as it approaches it as it goes to
infinity but in this case it's actually
bounded alpha is bounded
so we're at the the others preferences
so so the the incentive to acquire
others preferences is so again in the
Bayesian framework in an arbitrary
symmetric based a Nash equilibrium under
da there's no incentive to lower those
preferences because it's a dominant
strategy to its strategy truth and under
I a there is there exists a distribution
preferences such that some students have
an incentive to learn others references
so that's the the benchmark that we use
for the experiment design so in the
experiment we have the simple setting of
three students and three schools each
school has one slot and rank students
with the lottery so the payoff
distribution is going to be you know
does a is a good school so you get a
hundred points if you get a and C is a
bad school you get you get zero whereas
B there's some uncertainty about B so
it's it's better than a what probability
one-fifth and almost as bad as C with
probability for this so the uncertainty
here is on the realization of the value
of B so ex ante
they expect a payoff of B is 30 so
submitting a B C is a dominant strategy
so the only source of inefficiency in
this environment is if there is a at
least one student with high value for B
you assign B to someone with a low value
okay
so in the experiment we use a complete
factorial design so we vary the
mechanisms and the information to
acquire and the cost condition so the
[Music]
the mechanisms and the information to
acquire are between subjects whereas the
free versus costly information
acquisition is within subject so that's
primarily designed to enable learning so
here is features of the experimental
sessions so each session has 12 subjects
so we use randomly matching to avoid the
repeater game effects so for half of the
sessions they play basically turn around
ten rounds at the infrared the school
choice game with free information
followed by ten rounds with costly
information acquisition so the piece of
information you would need to to rank
the schools for free for 10 rounds and
then we say well now you have to pay for
it I'm going to talk about the details
of how implemented and then we also
reverse the order so thinking about the
order effect as you know in the costly
to free condition in the first ten
rounds you would need to learn a fair
amount of things you need to learn the
mechanism as well as the information
acquisition please whereas in the free
to costly we separate these two
processes so the first ten rounds you
only need to learn the mechanisms
whereas the last two rounds you need to
learn the information acquisition piece
okay so how do we elicit people's
willingness to pay in the lab yeah yeah
so so your value for school a and C is
the same for everyone but for PE it's
it's a random draw for everyone for
every person every round right so you
can imagine that under Boston it's
useful to learn what others valuation
might be
so we use the bekata guru magic
mechanism and so they can enter their
willingness to pay for either their own
value or others values and the server
collects their willingness to pay and
generate a random number between 0 and
15 if your willingness to pay is above
the random number then you find out the
information and pay the random number
otherwise you don't find out the
information pays zero and the
instructions are adapted from a prior
experiment basically we write as the
habib at all that you know you should
just tell your true willingness to pay
so that's how we elicit that information
the other piece is to to elicit their
beliefs so we we listed their beliefs
about others information acquisition and
so belief elicitation is is a fairly
actually messy enterprise so we use a
scoring rule called the binarized
scoring rule and the the basic idea of
the scoring rule so i have until did it
five o'clock right yeah okay so
basically the binarize query says that
if you're close enough you will get a
fixed price otherwise you get nothing
okay so the idea is true basically
bypass the curvature of the utility
function so you don't have to be
expected to utility maximizers two for
this illustration method to be an
incentive compatible and so this is
first analyzed by hussein and oh cool
all right so so one strength about this
paper is the battery of measurements
which enables us to decompose people's
willingness to pay so at the end of the
experiment we elicit people's risk
attitude using the hotel or a measure so
that's sort of a set of lotteries and we
also have a measure which we call
curiosity so basically the hotel or a
measure says for each of the ten
lotteries you know either choose this
you can tell us whether you want to
choose the safe or the risky lottery and
we you know determine your risk
preferences based on your switching
point and so usually the way it its its
implemented is that you know at the end
we say okay
lottery six is chosen randomly chosen
and your payoff is this instead we say
your payoff is this how much you're
willing to pay to find out which lottery
is chosen so that Alisa people's at that
point there's no utility from knowing
which lottery is used so we essentially
measure people's willingness to pay for
nine instrumental information so we we
call this curiosity it turns out that
this is going to explain a fair amount
of people's willingness to pay okay for
for information
so let me show the experiment data so
this is the combined data for people's
willingness to pay for their own values
in the immediate acceptance mechanism
and deferred acceptance mechanism what
you see the red bar these are the mean
plus minus one standard deviation in
that the red bar is when you have you
have to you know basically play the
school choice game and the lottery game
and there and the information
acquisition altogether in the first
round so that's the cost later free and
the blue ones are the free to costly so
you separate the understanding of the
mechanism with the with trying to figure
out how to figure out how to figure out
how to how much to pay for the
information so the bottom line of the
empirical result is all comparative
statics would go through but the levels
are off and so the empirical exercise is
basically to figure out why the levels
are off compared to the theoretical
prediction so what you see here the
dotted lines are the theoretical
predictions under risk neutrality and we
also look at the risk averse situation
it turns out it's the same essentially
the same same phenomena so yes so
people's willingness to pay under ia is
significantly higher under da but here
you're they see basically two features
one is that they're closer to the
theoretical prediction if they play this
in the second ten rounds compared to the
first two runs so there is some learning
and it seems that the cognitive load
matters okay
and you see very similar things with
willingness to pay for others values
again the comparative statics hold but
the levels are off
so the after we we got our data we
thought oh how interesting you know
access willingness to pay for
information but if you look at the prior
experiments of information acquisition
in voting or in the auction context it's
actually in every paper okay and and
people have different ways to
rationalize it such as regret avoidance
and what we do which is you know taking
advantage of the battery of measurements
is to decompose the the willingness to
pay so this is the Tobit regression for
the subject average willingness to pay
and and the the reason for using Toby it
is because 18 percent of our
observations hit the boundaries and what
you see here is what we pick up several
factors that seems to predict either
higher or lower willingness to pay one
is the proportion of times that you play
a dominated strategy with free
information so that only applies for the
da okay
so in our sample overall it's actually
not a huge amount a realized that we
discuss the you know whether people
recognize some of the strategies and so
on so it's 5% in the entire sample but
if you know if you're more likely to
play dominated strategy is you have a
higher significantly higher willingness
to pay curiosity which is what we use to
measure people's willingness to pay for
non-instrumental information is also
significant in predicting your
willingness to pay as well as we used to
what we used to call cognitive load and
sometimes people have people have issues
about whether it actually represents
cognitive load so if you play the costly
two three conditions so you give you
everything as soon as you start playing
the game you have higher what end us to
pay and risk aversion turns out that
once you control for demographics is no
longer a significant predictor but it
goes in the direction the theory
predicts okay so once we identify these
factors who are going to decompose the
willingness to pay so we have a random
effects panel Tobit regression which I'm
now going to show you it's in the paper
that's posted on our website so
basically in addition to the factors
that we picked up from the the the
regression that we presented before we
also picked up learning and conformity
so conformity learning is
straightforward which is the willingness
to pay decreases over telling as as
people accumulate experience with
information acquisition the conformity
piece basically says that people's
willingness to pay increases with their
guests of the average willingness to pay
of the other two participants so this is
puzzling because in this setting if
others if you expect the others to pay
more you should free ride on their
information acquisition and what we
observe is just the opposite so this is
we call it conformity so what you see
here is the decomposition of the subject
willingness to pay for information the
top line is the data in different
treatments and the bottom line here is
the benchmark which is the theoretical
prediction
so the I guess it's a more general
question but so here you find that
there's sort of extra willingness to pay
for information how do you square this
with the practical evidence that like
you know in like when we choose like
health insurance plans or annuity plans
or image choice we seem not to have the
information that we need to make those
important choices like hot sees hot
space work for example that you've
highlighted at the beginning that you
know low-income students don't know that
they can access like okay yeah so so
what
so we also find these people with zero
willingness to pay which is coming up so
so so right now we're just talking about
the averages and then we're going to
talk about the heterogeneity always
submit submitting zero so in reality you
know in the Hawks P Huck's B and
Turner's work
you know is it because they're not
willing to acquire information or they
it's a it's a it's a belief that it's
not there you know it is it's not clear
so the intervention where you send
financial aid information to students
has quite strong effect which means that
once you once you send the information
and it's in a very digestible form so so
I'm thinking of Sudan our skis field
experiment at the University of
Michigan's admissions office you know
it's a postcard which says that you know
if you you know they she targeted the
high achieving students in low si les
SES neighborhoods the public schools of
low SES and neighborhoods and and it
shows that the likelihood that they
apply for Michigan and also the the
yield rate are significantly higher than
the control condition so so that's more
of an information provision piece which
we're going to which also look at for
for the you know the welfare analysis so
so that's not students going out and
acquire information on they're always
just a student
the ghost car that landed in their
mailbox so I guess the way to
rationalize the fact that students don't
go and actually acquire this information
is that the cost of acquiring this
information is an out too high it could
be yeah oh they don't know where to
acquire the information
okay so for the 40 the decomposition so
for instance you know
what if you know how do we how do we
model learning we look at their last
period behavior and essentially replace
their first nine periods with their
tenth period behavior this strategy and
figure out how much learning explains
the the willingness to pay and after the
decomposition exercise will show that
conformity explains about between a half
to nearly a quarter of the willingness
to pay
and also a curiosity explains about a
quarter roughly of the of the
willingness to pay for information so
that's the first part which is on
average people have excess willingness
to pay for information and we also look
at the case where we also have about 15
percent of our subjects who always
submit zero right so these are people
who are not willing to acquire
information in this case for the DA of
the value it is the optimal strategy
whereas for the other treatments it's
not so the regression analysis that
looks at who have demand for for
information who have zero demand for
information identify this basically
curiosity people who are less curious
are more likely to have zero demand the
other one we don't really know how to
explain which is our Asian subjects are
more likely to submit zero demand for
information so one question is for
people who have zero demand for
information is it because they're not
good at using this information so if
they don't know how to use the
information then so it's a it's it's a
rational response and not to pay for it
and so the experiment design allows us
to actually look at this this conjecture
which is we have the free information
condition
so what you see here the white bar is in
the information provision case which is
the information is given to you the
postcard lands in your mailbox and so in
this case you have people who have zero
demand and those who have public sorry
this is positive demand and this is the
or the end it turns out that we can
reject the the hypothesis that zero
demand participants have they're just
not they're not as good as using this
information it turns out that they are
as good and in some cases better at
using the free information compared to
others and whereas the second hypothesis
is that castle information acquisition
hurt these people
while benefiting others who have the
opportunity to obtain more information
so we cannot
so this is a relatively small sample so
we we see the directional prediction
which is they are hurt by not not
acquiring information
there's also some welfare analysis we
also did some welfare analysis on the
information provision and acquisition
result I'm going to
talk about the three policy analysis one
is you know you can acquire information
if you like so this is very much in the
experimental setting so this is the Liz
affair design the other one the
counterfactual is you know we provide
free information on your own values and
costly information on others values and
second contracture is free information
provision on both your own and others
values the the bottom line of this is
that the counterfactual - is the best
which is free information on your own
values is welfare improving which which
makes matching more efficient so that's
that's understandable so why providing
information on others values this is
primarily because people even under DA
over acquire information even when
theoretically they should not so that
avoids wasteful gaming so let me wrap up
and talk about some of the real-world
examples of information provision so
what we have found in this very
controlled environment is that the
incentive for information acquisition
varies across mechanisms so we also
differentiate between information
acquisition on your own preferences
versus others preferences and and what
what they're useful you know for
preference formation versus gaming and
we show from our experiment that all the
comparative statics results in theory
are you know supported in data but the
levels are off
and so our decomposition and exercise
allow us to identify the empirical the
behavioral factors that contributes to
the over acquisition the welfare
analysis indicate that you know free
information on your peoples own values
our wealth
improving that's true in both theory and
experiment
whereas free information on other's
values theoretically there should be no
use under da because the strategy proof
in the experiment is actually welfare
improving under both mechanisms so what
are the decomposition exercise says that
the excess willingness to pay can be
decomposed primarily be accounted for by
curiosity which is the willingness to
pay for now instrumental information and
conformity I expect others to pay
therefore i you know to invest to
acquire information therefore I also
acquired
so so what does information provision do
they're sort of they can take several
forms in terms of policy implications
one is to make information that's
already there more accessible so
Hastings and Weinstein experiment is is
a good example where you have several
hundred pages of brochures on schools
which are alphabetically ranked all the
information is there but it's costly to
digest you can you know if you reduce it
to three pages of relevant information
actually changes people's choices the
other part is there are some
ethnographic studies of New York City
public schools which you know so these
are studies where the researcher would
go into the schools and interview the
students and counselors some of the
guidance counselor's actually advise to
the students that you don't need to rank
order of schools you you can just you
know maybe rank five and which is not a
good advice because New York City uses a
cap form of DA and you know at the end
of each year there are a fair number of
students who are unmatched so so
training guidance counselors and
teachers can be a much more effective
way of providing information on the
mechanisms site there there have been
some evidence that there are mechanisms
or implementations of mechanisms that
provide information on other people's
choices so one example is the Wake
County North Carolina mechanism they use
the Boston immediate acceptance
mechanism but allows parents so they
publish the the people who rank each
school as their first choice and allows
the parents and students to revise based
on that information
so that's one way to to provide
information on others preferences and
this this this example is from for Hideo
Kojima's so so if you look at the Japan
residents matching residency matching
program it has a very similar set of
information feedback so they list the
number of students who lists each
Hospital program as the first choices
and you have a period of time to revise
that's also true for the University of
Tokyo the most radical form is the
college admissions mechanism in Inner
Mongolia which is a fully dynamic da in
the sense that students can continuously
revise their preferences within a short
period of time where you know the other
students who apply for the same schools
and as well as their test scores my
doctoral student in July has working
paper with with Benning gold which
provides the theoretical analysis as
well as experimental evaluation of the
Inner Mongolia mechanism so here so
these are some of the the empirical
practice where others information or
strategies are provided so in this case
for example they show that it
outperforms the static immediate
acceptance and
to the deferred acceptance
time for one or two questions there or
any okay so you can also touch the
Android after the reception why don't we
think again again
[Applause]